hello hello everybody we apologize for
the delay and getting started I just
absolutely love when Zoom has updates
and we are working on getting everything
connected so if you did not have to do
an update then good job because you
already did it or your computer system
is smarter than we are
um but yes it is a fabulous fabulous day
here on ask Vet Live today but you can
use ask doc live still if you
um want to get in contact with us with
specific questions let me turn that
reminder off I'm already on oh what a
wonderful day so I hope all of you are
having a wonderful day also whether
you're just getting started or coming
towards the the dawn
or the dusk
Donna dusk we reach reach around the
world
um in being able to
bring information to everybody wherever
you are my name is Rebecca Dukes Kozak
and I am proud to be the host of this
program for the next two hours as we
bring empowering information to you in
regards to your fur babies feather
babies
Gill babies whatever you have that is
um pet related
today is your day
so we are bringing to you
oh the veterinarian that is a Pioneer in
concert conserving life in the animal
kingdom because he started in the animal
kingdom and for many of you if you do
not know and but do remember Marlon
Perkins of mutual Omaha's Wild Kingdom
Dr Wallach was actually the pathologist
for Marlon Perkins and he was
pathologist at the St Louis Zoo I mean
he's been at many many zoos and has
actually
with his research
obtained a two million dollar Grant from
the National Institute of Health 25
million
did I say it wrong again doc you had two
minutes 25 million
five million thank you
and that was worth what today
75 million
[Music]
because that was back in what year Dr
Wallach
um that was in
1967.
1967 you have been changing lives of
animals through nutrition
I think that is just absolutely
fantastic Dr wellick and we are excited
to be able to host this program with you
on it
and bringing information because
our animals are family too
we want to make sure that your whole
entire family is getting the nutritional
needs that it needs to have Optimal
Health and even for those who have
started on a health of decline
it's not too late in most cases and
that's what this program is being
brought to you for is to find out what
you can do as an empowered individual to
help your animals whether they're farm
animals whether they're domestic pets it
does not matter because the man that we
have on with us has seen them all
with over 400 and is it 32 or 52 Dr
Wallach species
for 450 450 let's go with that
all right so without further Ado welcome
Dr Wallach to
okay well thank you Rebecca and thank
you team for setting everything up
I'm sure this is gonna be a lot of fun
and we'll kind of uh as we go along here
months by month it's going to be great
and um so much we learn from animals we
benefit for humans and so it's kind of a
two-way street
and it's one of those things where
um you also when you have a chance you
can go what is it to Facebook to the Dr
Joel Wallach story is that correct
um so on YouTube on Wellness
Publications we have the Dr Wallach the
D that yeah the doctor
Joel Wallach story for sake of kids
so yeah and so yeah basically the reason
I'm bringing that up is um
uh when I was doing the
um work in the St Louis Zoo it was not
only pathology work but also clinical
work and
um uh had so many Publications and
speaking around the world because we
were finding out things that nobody had
ever seen before or they'd seen it and
had no clue they were blaming everything
on genetics and autoimmune the bodies
attacking itself
and I was able to prove that there are
no genically transmitted diseases and
animals are people there are no
autoimmune diseases and animal are
people the ones that are considered to
be genetic or autoimmune are just really
just simply nutritional deficiencies
and so as in in the beginning of my
experience
excuse me in the zoo of course uh
actually uh was working in the clinical
situation
um dealing with you know feeding uh
lions and tigers and bears vitamins and
minerals and and the small animals or
like in Little aquariums on display uh
and so forth making sure they got their
nutrients and so on
and we were seeing really great results
and then
um when after
that um first discovery
um when I was alone on a Christmas
holiday in 1963 I was a third year
Veterinary student at the University of
Missouri and all the professors were
gone I was working my way through school
by working in the Pathology Department
and this
um
sheep farmer or Rancher however you want
to call them brings me 50 dead Lambs
holy moly okay he did the autopsies on
them they all had huge goiters and so
um what happened was he was telling me
the day before all his 500 Lambs were
perfect he's getting ready in a week or
so to take him to Market and that
morning that he brought me the 50 Lambs
dead Lambs all 500 were dead they were
beautiful the day before
well 500 did the next day
and
um so obviously it was related to the
goiter in those lambs and so I just
checked with the weather service and in
Central Missouri
um where they were feeding those Lambs
um the winter temperatures in December
can be 40 50 60 degrees in this
particular time it was running in the
40s and 50s well the night they all died
the temperature dropped it had a
catastrophic drop down to 16 from the
day before which was 40 something 42 45
and it dropped down to um 15 and they
all died of hypothermia because they all
had a goiter all had a problem with
their thyroids
and so I started saying okay well where
would 500 Lambs get something to
interfere with their thyroids well it
turns out that all the Neighbors on the
neighbor Farms are raising a lot of hay
and so forth and they wanted Christmas
money and so they were pumping a lot of
of nitrate fertilizer to increase their
yield from their land
and the excess nitrate fertilizer is
going into the pond that the Sheep are
getting their water from and the
nitrates actually cause goiter in those
lambs and when the temperature dropped
they couldn't maintain their body
temperature so they all died from
hypothermia that was my first paper that
I wrote my first scientific paper I'm
only 23 years old
um a student I had my degree in
agriculture but I didn't have my degree
yet it was two years away from getting
my degree in in veterinary medicine and
um it got published in two Veterinary
journals in 1965 when I was going to
Africa to work on the White Rhino
conservation project from Arlen Perkins
he said I could come back after he had
things stabilized in in South Africa and
natal Province on Pelosi and Shish Louis
game Reserves
um the population of the White Rhino at
that time was only about 350.
and they're concerned of course that
some catastrophic event could wipe them
out in a year or two and so maybe
overnight and so my job was to catch as
many as I could and ship them back to
United States so make a long story short
um over a period of two years I had
caught over 200 White Rhino shipped him
back here United States
and by then
um Perkins and Barry commoner from
Washington University had gotten the 25
million dollar Grant from NIH
to look for a canary in the mine in
other words what we're looking for in
the big zoos and the big cities around
the world there's a species of animals
was sensitive to police remember that's
the the
mid-1960s and
um pollution was a big big big deal and
they were first recognizing the the
impact the catastrophic potentials and
so forth and they wanted me to come back
and do things that related to
um
the nutrition in the zoo animals and if
any of the zoo animals
died from pollution we were going to use
them like the canaries in the mine the
old coal mowers used to take canaries
out in the coal mines of gases who were
toxic would go in the mine that canaries
were more sensitive than men they'd drop
off the perch and die in the menu to get
out so um Perkins and Barry Connor the
director of the biology Department
Washington University of St Louis wanted
me to find a species or multiple species
of zoo animals that were sensitive to
the same pollutants that humans were so
if these zoo animals were to die from
pollution we knew to evacuate the cities
that was the whole purpose of the study
and that's why it was a 25 million
dollar study 10 years
and to make a long story short I found
out
was that um uh there was no genetically
transmitted diseases there were no
autoimmune diseases and the the
publication my thesis turned out to be 5
000 pages
okay five thousand pages I had done 20
000 autopsies seventeen thousand some
change over 450 species of animals and
three thousand in humans
and it was all coming together there uh
so that uh um when it was published as
the diseases of exotic animals uh WV
Saunders the big medical textbook
publishing house bought the rights to
the publishing that book my thesis and
they published it they've edited it down
from five thousand pages to 1200 Pages
which is a current page number and they
would sell them for twenty five thousand
dollars each say published initially
ninety thousand copies and they sold
them like almost overnight at 25
000 each that's because of the the
impact of the information from pollution
and people were you know universities
and medical schools and research
institutions and big companies that were
dealing with pollution everything we're
buying up those books like crazy
um you could go on Siri and every once
while you'll find a used one for sale
for five thousand dollars or twelve
hundred bucks or something like that if
it's beat up and dog-eared and so forth
used a lot and a lot of notes in the
margins and so forth
but again what I found that the the
major cause of death in the zoo animals
was nutritional deficiency just like it
was in the human population
and that's why that book was so valuable
that's where my thesis was so valuable
and
um it's um uh what what we do today of
course in the zoos we came up with what
we call arthrodex
um okay arthrodex is a
um a nutritional supplement for animals
and you use it yeah use a quarter of a
scoop of the arthrodex
um for birds and mice and rats and
guinea pigs and things like that and
then it goes up by body weight to
elephants so using arthrodex as a
supplement and it has interestingly
enough even though there may be
um
sort of herbivores they will eat and use
the the arthradex which is have it has a
base of beef uh dried beef but then it
also has the plant derived minerals of
75 plant derived minerals in it and then
of course you get up in into the larger
animals whether they're rabbits or dogs
and cats and lions and tigers and bears
and so forth you need more and more base
body weight and it gives you the the
dosages on the back of the label by body
weight for uh animals I mean if that's
all that was available I'd use it for
people also okay it's a great product
arthrodex and then also I like to use
the plant arrived minerals okay the 78
plant metals that come from the
um the the minerals that come from the
plants in the ocean okay now these
plants uh some of them are like 25
million years old and we get them okay
plant derived minerals and we extract
them and put them in a liquid and or we
make them available in powder okay these
same plant derived minerals are in the
arthradex
and it makes a huge difference now you
have to remember that it's the turn of
the 20th century
um the average lifespan of you know
family dog a pet was something like
three and four and five and six years
old a six-year-old dog was an old dog or
about 2 000 I don't know 2000 1905 and
these dog food companies started coming
up because they were doing all this
research in nutrition they were using
dogs and cats and so forth so they took
that information and made commercially
prepared uh pet foods and they put these
um minerals in there and guess what
suddenly now
dogs and cats are living to be 12 years
old 15 years old 20 years old because
they're getting all these nutrients and
so the same thing became true in humans
again you have to appreciate
um we can add 25 to 50 Health figures
your life one of the things that really
freaked everybody out was when I was
doing my autopsy research on animals and
people what I found was the
um things that were really seriously
thought to be genetic-like
um
to be a genetic disease of humans
found the first non-human cases
scissoribrosis in a monkey at Yorkie's
Primary Center when I told them it
wasn't genetic I didn't tell the public
I told the people at the University
Emory University was not genetic there's
a simple nutritional efficiency and they
fired me okay
in 19
um let's see here
1977. they fired me and so that's when I
went back to school it was a long story
but I got back to school and became a
naturopathic doctor licensed in 1982. so
I could start treating people and what I
found out was the average lifespan of a
medical doctor in America the average
um life expectancy of a medical doctor
in America was 58. 58. for doctors and
75 for
non-doctor humans okay so doctors
weren't doing very well because they
were eating snack food and quick food
and doing all this kind of stuff and not
taking vitamins minerals it might take
Vitamin C or something like that but
they weren't taking all 90 essential
nutrients and there they were then and
still pay a huge price for that they die
on the average of of um 58 okay that's
right that's their life expectancy the
human has the potential to live well
beyond 100 110 120 and my book
immortality goes it was a five-year
study that we did and the same
principles apply to animals
um when you look around the world there
are cultures who lived be 110 120 130
140 what's their secret says a genetic
no
what is it well they live near glaciers
and they live near volcanoes and the
volcanoes are spurting out all this
highly mineralized Ash and the Glaciers
are grinding up the walls of the um
valleys and in the water well because
these people use is a very high in
minerals for their animals and very high
in their minerals for them and so that's
why they live so long and and so that's
why we do that now for animals with hair
you can find out what their mineral
values are you know again that book uh
rare Earthman cures you can go to
chapter 10 11 page 272 and you can cut
the hair off of dogs and cats and
rabbits and anything fluffy okay and
send it in and tell them that it's you
know what species of animals it is and
they will give you a two charts one
chart is on the nutritional minerals
where they're at or if they're missing
or whatever and the second chart is on
toxic minerals like lead and mercury and
uranium and that kind of stuff and so
you can adjust
okay you can adjust the feed okay for
these animals uh base was the arthradex
which I love and also uh you want to put
say an
ounce of the the plant around colloidal
minerals okay the plant minerals put an
ounce there's 78 minerals in here and um
put an ounce of this in each pint of
water you put in their water dish okay
and they're gonna love it you got to
watch it because they will just go crazy
they love those minerals and you're
going to add many many Health Years to
Life by giving those two things now the
only thing I don't know and so I'm gonna
in the process of asking we'll find out
can they run the same nutritional test
that we do in hair analyzes in humans
and animals can we do it in Birds on
feathers you know say you can clip a few
feathers off of a wing of a off of a
canary or a parakeet or a two can or a
um a hawk or some kind of bird you have
or a chicken uh geese a parrot yeah yeah
there you go and uh so I believe you I
would believe you could but we're going
to find out and we'll get back to you
next next month when we do this again
and let you know if the feathers will
work on their same test okay and so
um with that you have to appreciate that
we've saved so many species by giving
them these minerals and vitamins and
their food instead of just throwing a
piece of meat to the tiger and tiger
love the meat but you have to think when
in the wild they're eating the skin and
the guts and the bones and they're
eating the lungs and they're eating the
livers where
animals whether they're a bird or a
mammal or a reptile they store minerals
and vitamins in the liver and so if
you're just eating the meat and that's
that's why in the old days of the slave
quarters okay
we we have the a book also called
black Gene lies black Gene lives goes
back to the slave quarter cures days
and this applies to animals were
it was not uncommon for the head slave
in a in a um Plantation
and some of his top uh Personnel so to
speak okay they would live to be 85 90
100 110
and this the plantation owner they would
die in their 40s and 50s and 60s what
was going on there well the these slaves
were using the wood ashes from their
fires and their their stoves and their
fireplaces and fire pits as fertilizer
for their Gardens and
the carrots and beets and onions and
cucumbers and so forth and corn we're
sucking up all those minerals from from
the burning the wood and the coal and
and which are 98 minerals the ashes are
90 minerals and two or three percent
um
carbon okay and so they're getting those
Minerals Well the plantation owners they
didn't want anything to do with that
anything the slaves did they didn't want
to have anything to do with and so they
were importing food from Europe from
another original country was from or
they're just eating meat you know
they're raising some calves and they
would kill the calf and they would eat
eat the meat and give the skin and the
liver and the bones and everything like
that in the guts to the slaves and they
would eat that stuff the slaves
nutritionally were getting a better deal
okay so that's why the slaves live
longer than the plantation owners
and let's see here with that said
um let's go to Rebecca and the team
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and thank you everybody for
bearing with us and having patience as
we're working on some technical issues
um with the lovely wonderful Zoom
platform which we have grown to
appreciate so much
um so we're going to give them Grace
while they're working through some of
their technical issues that create us
technical issues and you know it's just
we're a happy place happy family
um but one thing that I forgot to
mention in the beginning is this
wonderful disclaimer that we have to
read because of
uh the FDA and the content of this
program is to provide educational
information only for the importance of
nutrition and supplementation Food
Supplies around the world are empty and
void of what the body needs including
for our
animals and pets
um not just to survive but actually
Thrive and in this program we will be
sharing information that is coming from
a pathologist who has done over 30 000
autopsies now on over 452 species
including humans
and using that data and figuring out
okay why is this disease why is this
cause of death happening and looking at
the nutritional and mineral compositions
that come from that data and doing
correlations for me a numbers geek
that's fascinating for you hey it works
let's just go with it so these
statements again have not been evaluated
by the Food and Drug Administration and
the products discussed are not intended
to diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease and the information contained on
this Zoom is again for informational
purposes only if you are pregnant
nursing or taking medications please
consult your health care professional
before starting on any supplement
program now as we are going through and
taking questions from those who are on
live with us if you have a question make
make sure that you go to the zoom menu
and raise your hand because I'm going to
be going through and selecting the
people who have their hands raised in
the order that they have their hand
raised
normally this program is for humans but
we are not going to leave you out if you
have a human question or a pet question
we're going to go through them we would
like to do pet questions kind of as a
priority I do have several that were
emailed in that we're going to be going
through as well so Dr Wallach
without further ado
if somebody referred you to this program
get back with the person that invited
you
to this program whether you're on live
with us or watching a replay it does not
matter get back with the person that
shared it with you if it was through an
email because you're one of our valued
email subscribers with critical Health
news or ask doc live you can reply to
that email and one of our certified
holistic health coaches will get back
with you
if you have never spoken with anybody
ever ever ever about youngevity or any
of the products you can go to asdoc
live.com you will find all of the
products that are being mentioned on
today's program whether it's for pets or
humans they're there and you can use
that shopping cart in order to get the
products on their way to you
or use the contact us and we can help
you get the products that you need based
on your individual needs because there's
a lot of things to choose from folks
we are here to help you make sure you
get what is right for you based on the
education that we have received through
the Institute of holistic health that
teaches Dr wallach's programs and the
research that he has used has been so
invaluable for myself and about 1200
other graduates which I'm super excited
about because Dr Wallach you have
created an army
a crusade well that was the goal
Army what was that he said that was the
goal was to create an army
yeah and and the whole Focus
is
to help people find an empowering way to
maintain or regain their health
because we're not chemical deficient
folks our pets are not chemical
deficient it is mineral deficiencies
that have been linked to over 600
different nutritional deficiency
diseases
and if you've got it more than likely
it falls within those categories so Dr
Wallach let's go to the first hand that
is up and we have Christy Christy go
ahead and unmute yourself you are on
live with Dr Wallach thank you oh this
is so exciting I got your new DVD by the
way that or you're it's been around a
while your dad Doctors Don't Lie I can't
wait to watch it I'm so excited
um I called about Simon last week he is
a 14 going on 15 year old terrier mix
long body weighs about a little over 30
pounds I'm just about a month had them
on your protocol
um you just mentioned giving liquid
minerals I'm taking just started taking
the Kiwi minerals
um strawberry kiwi can I put that in his
water
would that work water
um and and so
um I let me say uh you could you know
it's the key we went but I think it's
probably okay right yeah okay
minerals but you know for the you know
general population
um it's just a little more economical to
go ahead and use just plain plant
minerals yeah I'll get those
um next time I just did my order so I'll
have to get them but um my question is
this his tongue has been he kind of has
his tongue hanging out at weird times
he's been a little short of breath and a
little bit not just a little very grumpy
and I have CBD oil I give him very
sparingly I don't know what else to do
I've got them on your protocol I'm out
of the MSM so I know I need to re-add
that but do you have any other
suggestions
um yeah
um of course you want to make sure
um of course the kiwi
minerals has a little bit of sugar in it
yeah maybe suffering from reactive
hypoglycemia low blood sugar uh kind of
thing going on there and so that's why
we do the plain minerals and then
and see if that doesn't help okay okay
all right thank you so much that would
be why is tongues hanging out I mean
it's kind of funny
sugar they feel exhausted oh
the same principle when a human beings
get a reactive hypoglycemia in other
words they eat a big dinner with a lot
of carbohydrates in it and you know
potatoes and spaghetti and stuff like
that it goes sit on the couch to watch
TV and a half hour later they're asleep
that's because their blood sugar gets
dropped
okay because they don't have enough of
the right nutrients to keep their blood
sugar up where it's supposed to be and
they fall asleep
I said what's the matter is you every
night after dinner an hour later you're
asleep I don't know I just got to Sleepy
once because her blood sugar is dropping
gotcha what do you think is hold off
then on the CBD oils I didn't know if
that was helping them or not I didn't
know if he was in pain yeah okay
okay and just follow the direction of
the bottle for the weight okay okay all
right thank you so much thank you so
much thanks for sharing all right
bye-bye
all right thank you Christy now Dr
Wallach I have an email that has come in
and vasha has a seven-year-old German
Shepherd male he's 85 years old
he's 85 years old I'm sorry 85 pounds no
he's not older than you times seven
that would be incredible that's like
Methuselah time but
85 pounds
um he was getting abscessed teeth and
then the vet had to take all of his
teeth out because they couldn't get the
infection under control and X-rays
showed that there is significant bone
loss now this is like
bread
top-notch breeder quality
German Shepherd doc
okay what's going on well he's got
osteoporosis of the skull that's why his
teeth were loose because the jaw and the
upper Dental arcade is part of the skull
and when the skull shrinks the holes of
the teeth are in get bigger and so the
teeth get Loosely get receding gums and
all that kind of stuff that's the clue
okay and of course if you've got
osteoporosis all over it doesn't it's
not just in the bones and the legs it's
also
in the skull okay a doctors and
veterinarians tend to forget this part
um that they can also get osteoporosis
of the skull you just don't get
osteoporosis of the right hip
okay the body doesn't work that way okay
and so here's where the Arthur decks is
a perfect
um and again it'll tell for you know an
80 pound dog just read the numbers on
the back of the label it gives the um
range of how much to give it for you
know he breaks it up into the smaller
animals is like you know per
ounce but in the bigger animals it's for
10 pounds it'll it'll tell you how much
of the arthroducts to to add to the dog
food use a good commercial dog food I
like canned dog food because in the
arthrodex mixes in it real easy when you
dry have dry dog food it kind of spills
to the bottom and dogs if they don't
like it which I don't see why they
wouldn't it's all made from beef they
love it but they'll blow on it and blow
the powder away saying just get the
crunchy dried food so I like the the
canned dog food with all the vitamins
and minerals in it so you can mix the
arthrodex in and then don't forget to
put the plant minerals one ounce uh on
the plant derived minerals per
um pint of drinking water in their water
dish and that should take care of the
problem very quickly
you're not Gary Rose teeth back but
yeah no it's kind of too late for that
one isn't it
to write Us in the hip
AA in dogs
um
nothing
I was wondering about that yeah and so
you know you can get arthritis in little
kids and of course hip dysplasia and
puppies and especially the larger breeds
they're not getting enough minerals as
their growth is occurring they're not
getting enough minerals into that hip
joint
but the same thing is happening in the
skull and the TMJ you know the temporal
mandibular joint uh it's also happening
in the shoulder joints and this and the
other and same way when people oh yeah
both my knees are gone well both your
knees are gone your hips are going your
vertebrae are going your skull is gone
your shoulders are gone your wrist is
going your fingers are going your toes
are gone but because of going up and
down stairs or you know you're spending
time walking or whatever it is you're
doing uh you're putting a lot more
pressure on those knees so you're seeing
the symptoms more on the knees but the
pathology is the same in every joint in
the body
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and the clarity and I love how
you go
um you know more into depth
when it comes to to to this and I mean
especially with animal stock I mean
because you and animals go way back
yeah well of course
oh yeah
um uh absolutely of course I grew up on
a farm and we were feeding that's how I
learned about human nutrition was
um I had what was called Tourette
Syndrome back then my parents took me to
20 different doctors between the ages of
four uh and nine and the the none of
them could figure out what I had and
what to do about it
and so they were going to put me in an
institution they're going to
institutionalize me well it doesn't
sound good to a nine-year-old what does
that mean 20 doctors couldn't figure out
got some horrible problem
they say you know
all those calves were feeding they never
have my problems what are they doing
different well they're eating those
Alfalfa pellets with all the vitamins
and minerals added to it so um that
night well I'm packing up they're going
to take me that's a Friday night they're
going to take me on Monday to this
institution where I'm going to spend the
rest of my short life okay in that
institution has experiment on me that
was it's a true story I went to the barn
and got a couple of quarts of those
Alfalfa Palace well the vitamins
minerals in it in Saturday morning
I you know took a couple of tablespoons
of them
um threw my cereal out and put just milk
on my Alfalfa pellets for the vitamins
minerals don't use that for cereal my
mom was shaking her head and screaming
at me but I said hey I'm going away on
Monday let me do what I want to do okay
and so I did the same thing on Sunday
morning I did the same thing on Monday
Morning by three o'clock in the
afternoon all my symptoms of Tourette
Syndrome were gone
just after three days on taking vitamins
and minerals and after five years of 20
doctors giving me Medical Treatments it
was getting worse
so when I was nine years old I knew the
doctors didn't know anything about
nutrition and the nutrition had a great
great great positive impact on really
things that doctors didn't know much
about
well and as a farm Kid myself Dr Wallach
I have a confession
I know what those Alfalfa pellets taste
like
and they're actually kind of sweet they
don't taste bad at all I never thought
about putting milk on them
yeah I just use them for cereal
yeah well and then you know rabbit
pellets is just a smaller form well you
got to read the label make sure they're
not putting wheat bread around oats in
them
right so that's you got to read the
label because you can still get messed
up eating the Alfalfa pellets that
they're putting wheat butter Orion oats
in there and so uh you got to read the
label make sure you're getting Alfalfa
pellets that do not have wheat bread
around ocean they can have corn they can
have rice
um they can have potatoes they can have
all kinds of stuff except wheat bread
around oats and no peanuts no peanuts
and tell us why no peanuts Dr Wallach
you have a really good reason I mean we
were told units were a good protein
well that's what we were told well that
may be true but they're a killer
um peanuts
um they're they are grown in the ground
and they get a
um infection okay uh with a fungus that
grows in the ground uh aspergillus
flavors and the estrogel slave is
produces a toxin called amphotoxin and
athletoxin is the biggest single cause
of liver cancer and liver cancer is the
third leading cause of cancer death in
America
liver cancer is extremely common all
over the world especially in countries
where they eat a lot of
peanuts so now you'll hear me I'm
changing what I'm saying I used to say
no wheat brought around oats well now I
say no wheat bread oats are
um peanuts and I don't have any of those
things okay and that's why because it's
going to significantly reduce your risk
of getting
cancer especially liver cancer
so does that also include peanut butter
because peanut butter goes through like
a heat process and grinding up and
no peanut butter ice cream uh no nothing
with peanuts in it okay and
um it's one of those things I actually
had one guy call me he says well you
know I've got a lot of peanuts here what
if I boil them he's thinking about
killing that fungus
well that
um aflatoxin is already impregnated the
peanut meat itself okay and so he was
well if I could boil them and kill the
fungus are they okay to eat and the
answer is no no no because if it was
just the fungus you're just eating the
fungus it might be another source of
protein for you but the fungus are
producing that aflatoxin terrible uh
terrible terrible poison you don't want
you know it's it's dangerous even to say
the word it's so poisonous
all right so folks you've heard it here
no
peanuts no peanut butter
and don't give them to your parents
either or your bears
or any of them especially if you want to
avoid liver cancer
yeah I was doing some research the other
day Dr Wallach and sure enough but I
came up with a couple different articles
that we're talking about aflatoxin and
you've been saying this for decades
when I came back um from Africa in 1977
the first thing uh was not only to do
those autopsies to look for
um pollutants and the zoo animals you
know for early warning signals
that Marlon Perkins gave me this list of
his personal interests and one of the
personal interests he had was bears were
dying in all the big zoos around the
world from liver cancer
almost every Bearer in the world in zoos
was dying from liver cancer at age 10 or
8 you know 18 to 25 years of age and it
Bears optimal lifespan if everything's
perfect they can live to be 65 70 years
old
and so why were all the Bears in all the
zoos all over the world dying well the
zoos were selling peanuts to the
visitors and the Bears learned to stand
up and wave their paws to get attention
and the people would throw the peanuts
at them they'd eat the peanuts well the
peanuts were all
um infested with that as fragilus had
the amphotoxin in them and so the Bears
are getting liver cancer and I got that
all figured out and wrote that up and
got it published and the international
Zoo yearbook
um there was one another one of my first
Publications and
um uh they switched over
to
um
um corn and dog food and stuff like that
you know the the Kibbles the the dry dog
food they were selling little packets of
dry dog food for the visitors and and so
suddenly now the Bears are all living to
be
50 60 70 years old and weren't getting
Liberty cancer anymore so I'm the guy
that got rid of liver cancer and all the
Bears in the zoos in the world
awesome that's that's fantastic Dr
Wallach good job well let's go to Ann
now who has her hand up with us and go
ahead and unmute yourself my dear you're
on live with Dr Wallach good morning
hi so I have a success story that I
wanted to share first well thank you so
um about a month ago
um my dog was having some issues he's um
three years old and he's a golden doodle
um and um we took him to the vet and the
vet diagnosed them with pancreatitis
um she didn't do any testing on it but
she said you know let's start there
um so she put him on a drug and that
wasn't really doing anything so I
contacted Rebecca and she suggested that
I try the pancreas support
and and after I got it I started him on
a Monday by Wednesday he was just about
back to his normal self it was it was
amazing it was like I got my boy back
um so so my question about this is um it
says that it's not for prolonged use so
I was wondering if I should stop after
one bottle yep I got that too okay good
so so I'm I'm gonna finish off this
bottle and then do you think then it's
just okay to stop it or should I do
another bottle well I get another bottle
but that only one during the week okay
so every day after you finish the first
just go to one serving a week
and add this okay answer decks and
uh let's see here
it wouldn't hurt uh to give an extra
um
uh 58 pounds he weighs okay I would go
ahead and
Stadium
um capsules to that dog also what what
capsules
selenium okay okay
as you can make the pancreas happy okay
that sounds good and then the other
thing I wanted to ask you was
um should he be taking efas too
oh yeah and the efas
um uh are essential for all living
things you know the
there's essential uh things are minerals
vitamins amino acids fatty acids fatty
acids
especially and so it um you say again 80
pounds 58.
58 okay there's an eight in there
somewhere okay 58 yeah
I'd go ahead and just give it one and
you you know one month through the efas
the next month to the fa plus those the
next one through the FAS next month for
the fa closes kind of just go back and
forth or you can get book calls and and
one day the amazing us you know and so
that way you're you're getting all the
possibilities
okay do you think do you think like one
one a day is good then yeah
fine okay
that sounds great so I have both of
those the efas and EFA pluses because I
take them too so yeah all right
well thank you for sharing the story in
your your story with your puppy dog that
will be a great great inspiration to um
dog families yeah
awesome thank you Ann and Anne if I may
say you're looking fabulous yourself oh
thank you very much I feel great good we
can see it oh yeah the energy the energy
is radiating out that's for sure
that is
fishing and I'm glad that that worked so
I know it works for humans and I'm
thinking okay we do a little dose for
your baby based on 65 pounds
it's not going to hurt anything yep and
it made a world of difference and
did what it was intended to do so that
is absolutely fabulous yep he's back to
running a zoo
uh oh what happened
oh I just love love love
Zoom Dr Wallach we're gonna take a break
right now and and Rebecca what Ann is
back
okay good
I don't know what happened in but we're
gonna take a break right now everybody
don't go away
we'll be right back after this short
break
all right and welcome back everybody to
ask that live my name is Rebecca dukes
and this program is being sponsored by
askdoclive.com you can also find just
our pet products on
svetlive.com but
hey
I know that we have to take care of our
pets but if we're not around to take
care of the pets who's going to take
care of them we need to take care of the
whole family everybody and that is
something that youngevity does such a
great job with in providing the 90
essential nutrients plus the secret
sauces that the body needs to be able to
regain the health Journey that we want
to be on so like anything else
once we realized that
we can choose our health Journey
and then there are options
it just
and that's something that I didn't
realize myself until I heard Dr Wallach
on the radio as many of you have
so I absolutely love Dr Wallach his
research his message how he used all of
that scientific data through collection
in his pathology work and related it to
dis ease
so
yes and we are having some wonderful
time with zoom today
and hopefully when Dr Wallach comes back
in there won't be any audio
interruptions or video interruptions
um
is able to do a little bit of remote
tweaking so hopefully
I know what I'm doing but if not hey
we're glad you guys are here just love
us keep coming back we're gonna get it
right
um it has been over two years that we
have been doing the ask doc live show
and
I absolutely love the fact that we are
able to be around the world
around the world
so
if you are joining us from somewhere
other than the United States in that
Zoom
um menu
oh there docs back doc let's see can you
unmute yourself
how's that
that is good
okay as long as so I feel like I'm on a
boat now so don't shake don't shake the
computer
because you're like
perfect perfect perfect all right
so Dr Wallach let's go to the next hand
that is up and Rob go ahead and unmute
yourself you're on live with Dr Wallach
hi doc hi Becca uh hi Rob hi guys yes
sir can I help you okay Doug first I
have a testimonial
um you know I've been suffering with
depression for a long time and you and
Char have been helping me out greatly
and uh synaptive has been doing Miracles
my god I've haven't felt so good in 20
years Doctor it's incredible you've had
so many people who have
contacted us regarding to the results
they get with the synaptic I don't think
we have 5 000 products I don't think
we've had another product where people
would call us so often and tell us how
remarkable it is because it does deal
with their emotions it deals with their
memories it deals with
um sensory stuff hearing and vision it's
a great great product synaptic I take
three twice a day
yeah I'm taking your recommendations too
so
um and I'm also on BP
um uh Tangy Tangerine 2.5 uh do you have
a preference between the tablets or the
powder
I use a powder could I use a drink
I make a drink out of it and so I can
put other things with it
the tablets are not the same as the
powder the tablets are primarily for
pain relief and also anti-inflammation
the powder has 215 nutrients in it for
two different things because they're not
um
biochemically the same
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna switch my order
right now then uh I'm also on efas of
course
um I have glucogel now in collagen
peptides and I have some MSM on the way
um now uh plank derived minerals maybe
I'll have to order that too now uh King
my cat you know King You've seen King on
our Zoom uh he's about 10 pounds
so how much should I give King for of
that
okay well it says right on the back it
gives you the numbers you know how much
per up to 25 pounds of body weight or 10
pounds of body weight whatever it is and
so basically I like to to do it let them
choose so what I do is put an ounce of
the plant minerals into a pint of water
in their water dish
of the toilet down so they can't drink
the tunnel water and they will drink
that water at the rate at which uh
especially in the beginning they'll
drink a lot of water because they want
those minerals now once they kind of
catch up and get the reserves in their
body they'll start slowing down except
obviously during the heat of the summer
they'll drink more water with the
minerals in it you're right okay
fantastic I'll order that too then uh
other question I had was a concern about
titanium dioxide I noticed that's in
some of the products like synaptiv
um what are your thoughts on titanium
dioxide is it good or bad for us or um
or our animals
your thoughts on that well yeah that's
why it's in there
it was bad we wouldn't we wouldn't have
the product okay yeah so titanium
thallium these things are good for brain
function also good for thyroid good for
adrenal glands good for pituitary glands
good for skin good for bones
and so you know it's one of those things
where
um
you know everybody knows about calcium
and Bones that's only one of 90
essential nutrients and that's why we
came up with the
um uh that's why we came up with the
healthy brain and heart pack it has 215
nutrients in it the core is still the
90. but when you look at all the
nutrients that are in there you know
look look at the minerals that are in
the plant-derived minerals
okay and when you look at um another one
another one of my favorites is was a
five-year project
we chase down the long-lived families in
the United States we chase down the
lungs of cultures in the world you know
the ones that lived be 120 130 140 and
we chase down and and found out what it
is they consciously proactively avoid
and what is they consciously proactively
do
okay and all that five-year study is in
this book immortality it'll blow your
mind information in this book can add 25
to 50 healthful years your life but you
got to do everything you got to avoid
all the bad stuff they avoid and you got
to
well doc Pros on us yeah Dr Wallach
froze on us
um so we are
done um and
um
do is just loaded with minerals and so
that's actually a support the minerals
are so important and then when you go
back again to the beginning of of the
19th um of the 20th century excuse me
being in the 20th century
is it was very obvious that um the
cultures they were do they're doing
something different they're living
longer because the people who were just
living like Europeans and Americans and
so forth
we're only living to be half
the longevity of these other cultures
and so this is
um very very well documented
great okay uh now as far as my
osteoporosis of this skull
um well we talked a while ago about my
jaw when I had extreme pain about that
and loose teeth I started to uh tighten
up again now so uh that's good so should
I consider the uh healthy heart and
brain pack or stay with the tangy
tangerine and all the other issues I
would go with the more complete thing I
would go with the healthy Brandon hard
pack how much do you weigh Rob I'm about
uh 200 and dropping right now
okay so I go ahead with two healthy
brain and heart packs and don't forget
that collagen peptides don't forget the
MSM
um don't forget the synapses
and uh um again
um like I say uh
I also take extra if I'm going to do
stuff out in the yard
I and we have a very big yard with a big
Gardens and things and so I do a lot of
stuff
and we chop wood for the fireplace and
all that kind of stuff and so um we also
use the um Luca gel which was our first
collagen we use in our healthy Bone and
Joint pack for Theo Ratliff and so now
we have the collagen peptides and the
MSM plus the global gel so I take three
glucogel twice a day in in my daily
stuff okay I take about 75 different
products plus my three eggs twice a day
and it's one of those things where if I
want to do something really strenuous
and physical I'll take five of those
glucogel capsules twice a day instead of
three twice a day just to kind of ramp
up a little bit and make sure remember
I'm 83 years old
and so it won't be long I'll be 84. and
so
um most people think I'm in my 50s and
so that it's one of those things where
I've been taking these nutrients for as
Rebecca points out over 75 years
and it pays off it pays off
um you know it probably cost me
because I'm taking a lot of stuff it
probably cost me 10 bucks a day for
supplements okay
but you know an average person could do
a very good job on three or four bucks a
day which is you know like a couple of
cups of expensive coffee in one of those
coffee houses
and you had 25 years of your life
you know speaking of looks I I just have
to comment again because I'm always
astounded with Becca it looks like she's
reversed another 10 years of age off her
already she's looks like she's heading
into her teens again so come on Becca
give us a secret
and no I did not pay him to say that but
thank you so much Rob that's that's
awesome and I can hear in your voice my
friend
night and day difference
oh
yeah yeah well you know how bad eye in
shape I was especially during the covet
situation and that and dealing with the
murder of my mother still everything on
top of me and uh it was really getting
into deep uh severe depression and uh
um I
um
was going to be forced on drugs nope
um and uh I'm on these uh minerals now
all the product and I am not going back
I'm not going back uh yeah I'm moving
ahead with youngevity and everything in
that respect too so another testimonial
uh you know and I wish I had all these
products for my mom as well too uh it
would have made a world of difference in
our lives so there you go so we're
sharing your information which is a
great thing yes and we owe a lot for
sharing your information thank you so
very much oh yes we're going where'd you
go going to go big with all this stuff
so there we go uh one last thing about
plant derived minerals um I have some
Prides angel fish and some koi and that
too
um so I'm looking at uh basically a 50
gallon tank uh to a hundred gallon tank
so
um how much should I put into there
well that would start up again at 50 I
would start out with an ounce just
turned out with an ounce
okay every day okay and I believe that
the the plants the aquatic plants that I
have in there and I have uh plants
emerged from there too they're going to
benefit from that also oh absolutely the
plants in the water will suck up those
minerals and some of those fish uh will
eat um some of the plants and so they'll
get minerals that way as well
I'm trying to prevent them from eating
the plants but yeah yeah but then it's
if I'm making a complete ecosystem and
uh I know very well that uh that this
secret is to have the proper minerals
and everything involved there too so
there you go so um hope that I'm going
to have longer living fish as well too
so that'll be fantastic
there you go okay well thanks Doc thanks
Becca I appreciate everything thank you
so much for sharing Rob
bie all right thank you Rob you're such
a sweetheart
yeah that is a great story
he does have a great story well yeah he
absolutely absolutely does have a great
story so I'm glad that he came on and
shared that with us today doc
now Elizabeth who's on with us she wrote
in the chat she says my 16 year old Papa
Lilian has a contract now
Elizabeth if you could come on with us
is that a cataract Maybe
can you Elizabeth can you are you able
to unmute
um because she's wanting to know what's
a good take way to deal with it so go
ahead I'm sorry yes I'm here
a 16 year old Papillon with a cataract
so cataract Doc and I
yes
okay well dogs and cats get them
cataracts too
okay and you have weighs how much
six about 13 pounds 13 pounds okay well
I would just give it
um one
um Vision FX
a day you know along with the doses of
the arthro decks okay One Vision FX
today and also it's again one
Beyond audio
now let me back up here
um let's see here ultimate daily classic
that's what I'm looking for ultimate
daily classic one ultimate daily classic
and
um one serving of the
um arthrodex
okay
so that way you're going to get
circulation into the eye and also
vision effects
you're gonna you're going to
um get something very specific for the
tissues in the eye oh okay so perfect so
what what do I do I call in to your
phone number and order that
Rebecca tell her
yeah so Elizabeth you can call our 800
number
800-984-3377 if you have never spoken to
anybody about
um any youngevity products before
um if you have get back with your
distributor or you can call our
corporate office but we have a great
group of people that if you even if you
know your youngevity ID number they can
help you place your order again that's
800-984-3377
so okay so thank you I have another
question I have been diagnosed in 2016
with Parkinson's
and I'm finding that I eat wheat and
Cheerios and granola bar all the time
you know oh my God so you think that's
contributing to it well of course uh are
you taking any statin drugs or you could
actually avoid Industrial
I'm taking carpentopa
okay well here's your problem
you need to get rid of all the bad stuff
no fried foods no processed Meats no
oils or pollutants oats so peanuts no
sugar no corny drinking that one's got
to go because carbonation and the diet
drinks will neutralize your stomach
gases so you cannot absorb minerals are
digestive so you got to get rid of all
the carbonation
and then let's see here how much UA
um 145.
145. oh gee three eights twice off yolks
soft boiled
um soft poached sauce I have mine saw
scrambled in butter okay
um because 25 of your brain weight and
25 of your uh spinal cord weight is
cholesterol you need the cholesterol and
then oh my gosh take three of those
twice a day the synaptive
and
um again two doses a day to two they
held abandoned Park to follow some
breakfast and dinner don't forget the
um MSM take three of those represent
your dinner that'll be two uh bottles a
month
and um
let's see here and also throw the
collagen peptides and scuba that with
your morning drinks with your evening
drink don't forget the vitamin D3 of
those for breakfast and dinner
and uh don't forget this oh my gosh
you're gonna have a great story okay
great uh so I just stopped
turkey don't call turkey off the
medication
what you want to do is say you know a
week or so
cut it by about 10 and oh cut it again
and then if you're really getting rapid
benefits you can cut by 25 you know but
don't just hold turkey off the
medication before you start a program
okay so here I find that I like granola
so after listening to you I'm trying to
think what what I could what can I eat
in the morning for breakfast with eggs
rice
um I also have
um a potatoes a yogurt with the berries
blueberries or strawberries
um
I also like salmon
and um um let's see here
uh other um let's see here breakfast
fish salmon
um this is a good one uh I've heard
about Dr Wallach I'm sorry chicken of
the sea yeah the chicken of the sea tuna
oh yeah
[Music]
tuna again fillets I don't like the
grass that's in a can or something like
that I like the fillets that are steamed
okay
sounds delicious so can I ask you
another question
go for it oh okay thanks my my husband's
been diagnosed with prostate cancer
okay well cancer is always problematic
okay
um and so in other words he's got to get
her all dead Foods too no fried foods
will processed means the oils or gluten
so we've been Rhino Oceano
um peanuts he needs to stay away from
carbonated drinks and sugar and then how
much does your husband weigh about 185
okay he needs two Health abandoned heart
pasture months a photo of everything
twice a day he needs
um the um MSM he's two bottles a month
so you can take three at breakfast
dinner time and they're going to support
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue including the
bone marrow which produces the white
blood cells and antibodies and platelets
and red blood cells is all part of the
immune system to help defend against
that prostate cancer right
okay and then what else would you
recommend Rebecca
Dr Wallach I'm really liking the Z
radical and what I've heard about the Z
radical Okay C radical there you go
I know it's funny because
um and uh his size with the prostate
cancer he could start out with a half
ounce twice today and if it doesn't give
him diarrhea he can go try and take
announce twice a day it comes in quartz
and he has the mattress from I don't
know eight or nine or something
seaweeds and
sea Keepers and helping all that kind of
stuff from the ocean
and so it really really helps each of
them in the bone marrow so I was going
to ask you does that help lower the PSA
score or does that stop the what uh
that's the goal the goal here is to
lower the PSA
okay I did I will I would not give up
because you don't want to be encouraging
the growth of prostate when you have
prostate cancer so I would not have them
take prostfx
okay do not take pronounced effects I
would just take all the other stuff that
we just mentioned but stay away from
process
there is one more product Dr Wallach
that includes beta glucan that is not
from oats
um that has been found in boosting the
immune system and allowing
um the strength of the cells that
through some of our protocols have been
um found to be very beneficial and
that's the RvB 300
using beta glucan
so I know where to wear formulators one
of the companies that youngevity brought
into their
umbrella of products AJ Lanigan who is
an amazing researcher
um brought in that product and it has
been found to be very beneficial with
any type of
um
attack on the cells okay well there you
go okay well thank you very much I
appreciate it thank you for answering
three questions yeah well that's right
keep in touch with us every couple weeks
will you yeah
absolutely Elizabeth and and for anybody
that's on with us
sorry
all right anybody
we've got all types of wonderful things
going on today dog it's been an
interesting show
um and I think that we are gonna end it
a little early today folks because of
technical issues with Dr wallach's audio
and video I don't even know here I'm
even having a hard time getting myself
spotlighted
um if you can hear me fine so
I can hear you we've got you can hear me
I'm glad you can hear me okay well maybe
we can go on with another question
let's go so I don't have any hands up at
the moment but Dr Wallach I have
somebody who has a four-year-old
Persian
who has been diagnosed with feline
leukemia
what would you recommend she's down to
four pounds Dr Wallach four pounds okay
well
um I I offer that the cat the
um
Arthur Dix okay in in the cat food
preferably canned cat foods it's moist
so you can mix the arthrodex into it and
again it gives you the amount of
arthritic to give per pound of body
weight so it's good
and uh it has
a quarter of a scoop for you know three
ounces a half a scoop for a half a pound
and it tells you how much you give for
each kind of weight category I would
also add one ounce of the plant minerals
per
say a pint of drinking water in the
water dish for the cat make sure there's
no other sources of water because you
wanted to drink those minerals okay and
then
um
uh let's see here
I'm trying to think also
um I would I would go ahead and add the
uh something like the BTT 2.0 tablet you
can just kind of grind them up a little
bit and put them in the food and that
will support the immune system as well
as
um
the rebuilding system okay
yeah so because you're giving your body
the antioxidants which help to reduce
inflammation plus the nutrition so
without that inflammation you're going
to get better absorption
because the inflammation is not like
swelling and keeping things from
absorbing right yeah the BT yeah the BTT
2.0 tablets is used very heavily in in
humans with cancer because again it
supports the immune system as a pain
reliever anti-inflammatory so it covers
a lot of territory but it's not a
replacement for vtt 2.0 powder which has
the nutrition in it they're two
different things I don't know why they
gave the same name but they're two
different things
well I take both
I do too I do both
and I like my pinky Tangerine my Osteo
effects mixed I've been doing I used to
do it in like 24 ounces of water and
then drank it all through the day but
I'm really liking putting it in about
eight to ten ounces of water with half a
banana and mixing it up really good just
makes a really yummy yummy drink and
I'll even put i26 or hyper immune egg
powder in there just for added immune
support
because
you know now that I'm not living out in
the country and I I'm coming in contact
with like real humans oh my goodness
um I just want to have that extra extra
boost of possible protection I'm glad
you do that because we have 5 000
products and I can't use them all
personally I'm gonna help you doc okay
I'm gonna help you so once you're not
trying because I'm not gonna give you it
I use at least 75 to 100 different ones
each day but I can't use five thousand
well no and see I'm not going to use the
Zera test or the prostaff X so you can
use those I'll use the Zara fim I'll use
the bust effects and the woman's affects
and the woman's hormone balancer which I
absolutely love I don't have any type of
mood swings or anything like that no
cramping
it just asked me
um I'm a perfect angel all the time now
well your energy your energy tells it
all your smile tells it all okay and so
uh and your recall you're able to
remember all the things that you've
learned and so forth and share with
others
um so we're very very proud of you and
thank you for taking on the
responsibility to be a great angel
well thank you Dr Wallach I appreciate
that we have Cynthia with her hand up
Cynthia go ahead and unmute yourself
thank you so much Becca thank you good
morning can someone over a new trip fi
and guess what I'm asking you you can
you be taking the 2.0 tangent Tangerine
plus you can be taking your plant
derived minerals added to that all day
long and is that all is that fine also
dog
no I do that I take the plant minerals
I'm taking two of the healthy brainer
heart pasture month and I take the plant
minerals every day plus I take the BTT
2.0 tablets
I mean uh I I I I take the collagen
peptides I I take the collagen the the
gel
and I take the ultimate daily multiple
we have the ultimate daily attempts to
take three of those twice a day I take
the old daily class or have low pressure
problem but take the old daily plastic
just to prevent blood pressure issues
and support healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries
and so I take a lot of stuff I mean I'm
just giving a small portion remember I'm
taking 75 different uh every day and uh
synaptive memory effects I take my
effects I take synaptive and memory
effects
um and then take my three eggs twice and
so that means I'm eating six chickens a
day because each egg after 26 days of
incubation
will hatch a full
chicken
okay so when I'm eating six eggs a day
I'm eating six chickens a day because
all the nutrients in those eggs
will grow a chicken isn't that crazy
wow wow okay one more question doc yeah
pardon me dog
did you ever think of it that way when
you eat when you yes sir
yes if you need three twice a day you're
eating six chickens a day yes well
nourished high protein
I have another question doc zero Femme
zero Femme is not a big product for
someone with fibroids or a young a young
lady who is a young girl who is 12 year
12 years old and having very difficult
um menstrual cramps and all of that is
that is that fine yeah yes it is
seraphim
um it goes by body weight if they weigh
like 120 pounds
which
is
Dr Wallach is again having some
technical issues and seriously
we've got to figure something out Zoom
is not our friend today
um so unfortunately when we were getting
now are you back doc because I know the
camera's not back is your voice back
no
get on to deal with all these side
effects
[Music]
okay are you interrupting me because we
gotta move on or well it's not that we
got to move on Dr Wallach you are like
not there for about 30 seconds
so we're having some technical issues
still
um Cynthia go ahead and give us
um
write us an email
okay
go doc at drjwalik.com
with information and we'll get your
question answered there okay thank you
so kindly all right you're very welcome
and folks since we are having the
technical issues that we are having
rather than trying to struggle through
it and not be able to get the
information that Dr Wallach is providing
to us nice and clear
we're just going to call it a day
go out have yourself a wonderful day
visit our stocklive.com
um and there you will find the good
foods bad foods list make sure that you
get that list printed out have it
available and focus on those good foods
I know when I focus on the good stuff
I'm not missing other stuff that it
sells me not to eat because it's not in
the Forefront of my mind I'm focused on
the things that I can eat which that
whole list is
full of yummies and
also yes
I mean there's so many foods I'm and if
you don't follow me on Facebook you
should because I share something almost
every day when it comes to foods and
stuff that I eat that's gluten free and
the doc approved list of foods
um because there there is there's so
much that we can eat without
without adding those toxins without
adding those bottled oils that are
causing clogged arteries and blockages
and
you know the need for pharmaceuticals
because we're not chemical deficient
we're nutrient deficient
so folks
we're gonna go get back with the person
that invited you to this program you can
go to askdoclive.com and
find all of the replays for the
ass.live.com program
you can also find our last ask vet live
there that was done on the first Friday
of September we're in October now keep
my month straight
um and get more information and I just
want to thank my co-host Heather Bowen
Dr Judy Reynolds and Ruth Ellen Sanchez
for keeping that chat rolling and
providing information there on how you
can get in contact with us if you were
not referred to this program and
if you are not already working with a
youngevity distributor we want to make
sure that your information and your
order history all of that stays together
is that person has a vested interest in
helping you we want to make sure that
they have that opportunity although we
love you all and we love having this as
a resource that supports the community
as a whole but we want to make sure that
everybody is getting back with a person
that invited them to this program Dr
Wallach thank you so much for joining us
um I will be coming to visit you and
figure out what's going on because I
wasn't able to do it remotely today but
next week we will see you here same
place same time on ass doc live share
with a friend my name is Rebecca dukes
and and till next time bye for now
bye-bye thank you so much bye everybody
thank you thank you team love you guys
thank you bye everybody